[Music]
this chaos
thousand people in an iron box
18 years i've hated my train
18 years i've waited for this moment
this is the world the train saved
humanity
the engine lasts forever the population
must always be kept in balance i said
sit
down passengers
eternal order flows from the sacred
engine
we must occupy our pre-ordained position
i belong to the front you
belong to the tail no don't play
keep your place those bastards in the
front think they own us
we'll be different when we get there
what you say
we take the engine and we control the
world
when is the time soon
this is disorder we're going to the
front
open the gate we know you well mr curtis
we've been watching you precisely 74
of you shall die
everybody i'm not a leader
this is your destiny
[Music]
harlan started out with a rusty smith
corona and built himself into one of the
best-selling mystery writers of all time
30 languages over 80 million copies sold
you guys fans i mean i don't do much
fiction reading myself
big fan i'm a big fan who is that guy
mr blanc is a private investigator of
great renown i read a tweet about a new
yorker article about you
you're famous the night of his demise
the family had gathered to celebrate
your father's 85th birthday
and your son ransom did he attend as
well yes but he left early i think linda
was upset
walt would get a little irish courage in
him he'd get into it with harlan
what richard said what
are you baiting me detective attempting
to be thorough so we can figure out the
matter of death you mean if someone
killed him do you think one of us one of
his family
killed him mr blanc i just buried my
father who committed suicide why are you
here
i suspect foul play i have eliminated no
surprise
harlem was cleaning house everyone
the family has possible motives was
holland planning on cutting off johnny
did he plan to file walter is richard
having an affair
that's some heavy duty conjecture funny
ransom you skipped the funeral but
you're early for the will reading
up your ass very
[Music]
the family is truly desperate when
people get desperate
the knives come out this is a twisted
web
and we are not finished untangling it
not yet
i keep waiting for the big reveal
all of them lied to me there is
one guilty party behind it all
you know something spill it
oh my god tell me what happened to my
grandfather
i think you have something you want to
tell me
most of the intelligence community
doesn't believe he exists
[Music]
the ones that do call him the winter
soldier
[Music]
he's a ghost you'll never find him
[Music]
a joint shield to protect people
to build a better world sometimes means
tearing the old one down
that makes enemies
are you ready all it takes is one step
people are gonna die i can't let that
happen
captain america needs my help
when do we start we just did
price of freedom is hot
and it's a price i'm willing to pay
he told me not to trust anyone this is
how it ends
everything goes
looks like you're giving the orders now
captain damn right
how do we know the good guys from the
bad guys if they're shooting at you
they're bad
please don't make me go you can keep
homeschooling me
i'll tell you everything i know no more
argument okay we've discussed this ad
nauseam what's odd nauseam
you don't know well it looks like
someone needs school
[Music]
who can tell me what three plus three is
everyone knows it's six
barry can you stand up please can you
tell me what 57
multiplied by 135 is
okay 7695
the square root is 87.7 and change now
what does ad nauseam mean
i listen to the wind to the wind of my
soul
i think your niece may be gifted i am
good friends with the headmaster of the
oaks academy for gifted education
no i promised my sister i'd give mary a
normal life
i think she's got to be here i've sat
upon the setting
son who's that lady in front of our door
that'll be your grandmother holy it's
the macbook darling
what are you doing you are denying the
girl her potential how many
seven-year-olds are doing advanced
calculus
forgot the negative sign on the exponent
mary why don't you say anything bank
says i'm not supposed to correct
older people nobody likes a smartass
we petition the court to grant my client
full custody of the child
no you're going to take that girl you
can loan her out to some think tank
where she can talk non-trivial zeros
with a bunch of old russian guys for the
rest of her life and you'd bury her
under a rock
evelyn stop i'm raising her how i
believe diane would have wanted
do you need a reason
we should commit treason if anybody
takes that baby away i'll smoke you in
your sleep
my sister wanted mary to be a kid she
wanted her to have friends
and to be happy tell us do you have a
health insurance no
did you spend the night in jail
objections and leave the
valleys what's your greatest fear
that'll ruin mary's life
she's bossy i've heard that
[Music]
he's a good person you wanted me before
i was smart
[Music]
this job we try to save as many people
as we can
[Music]
sometimes that doesn't mean everybody
but you don't give up
new york
washington d.c
circovia
okay that's enough captain people are
afraid
that's why i'm here
we need to be put in check
whatever form that takes some game i'm
sorry tony
if i see a situation pointed south i
can't ignore it
sometimes i wish i could sometimes i
want to punch you in your perfect
teeth i know we're not perfect
but the safest hands are still our own
i was wrong about you
the whole world was wrong about you
[Music]
they're coming for you i'm not the one
that needs to watch their back
this doesn't have to end in a fight tony
you just started a war
[Music]
stay down final warning
i could do this all day
all right i've run out of patience
hey everyone
exposure to a high-energy cosmic storm
could advance our knowledge about
planetary life to our future
i don't trust him we got what we wanted
just worried about what he wants
now your entire biophysical structure is
changing
it's terrible news i think i'll get a
second opinion
[Music]
the cloud has fundamentally altered our
dna
that's gross reed look at me
i can't he's hitting him from his core
you don't want to walk run on fire for
the rest of your life do you is that a
trick question
come on by the only guy who thinks this
is cool what if we got these powers for
a reason
i've always wanted power
victor you always thought you were a god
let's not fight no
let's
don't even think about it never do
flame on
[Music]
oh you're hot why thank you so are you
god seems like a thousand years ago
i fought my way out of that cave became
iron man
realized that love to you
i know i said no more surprises but i
was really hoping to pull off one last
one
the world has changed
none of us can go back
all we can do is our best and sometimes
the best that we can do
is to start over
i saw all these people die
i keep telling everybody they should
move on
some do but not us
even if there's a small chance
we owe this everyone is not in this room
to try
[Music]
we will whatever it takes
[Music]
whatever it takes whatever it takes
[Music]
whatever it takes
[Music]
[Music]
i like this one
[Music]
you